सभी ऊर्जावान प्यारे बच्चों, गणमान्य
अतिथियों, देवियों और सज्जनों
सभी को नमस्कार।
राष्ट्रीय ऊर्जा संरक्षण पुरस्कार 2025 के
इस समारोह में भाग लेकर मुझे प्रसन्नता हो
रही है। मैं सभी पुरस्कार विजेताओं को
हार्दिक बधाई देती हूं।
उन्होंने ऊर्जा संरक्षण के क्षेत्र में
महत्वपूर्ण योगदान दिया है और नवीन
टेक्निकों के माध्यम से प्रभावी प्रयास
किए हैं। आज पुरस्कृत बच्चों को मैं
बहुत-बहुत बधाई देती हूं। उन्होंने ऊर्जा
संरक्षण के विषय पर अपनी कल्पना और
संवेदनशीलता को सुंदर चित्रों के माध्यम
से प्रस्तुत किया है। बच्चों के लिए तो
थोड़ा ताली हो जाए।
[प्रशंसा]
बच्चों की सृजनात्मक अभिव्यक्ति से उनकी
सोच और दृष्टिकोण के साथ-साथ उनकी आशाओं
और सपनों का भी पता चलता है। ऐसे
प्रभावशाली बच्चे भविष्य में गहन एवं
सकारात्मक परिवर्तन का मार्ग भी प्रशस्त
करेंगे।
अगर देश के बच्चे और युवा ऊर्जा शरण के
शरण के महत्व के बारे में जागरूक हो जाए
और इसके लिए प्रयत्न करें तो इस क्षेत्र
में लक्ष्यों की प्राप्ति तथा देश का
स्थाई विकास सुनिश्चित किया जा सकता है।
भारत विश्व की सबसे तेजी से बढ़ती हुई
अर्थव्यवस्था में से एक है। विकास की इस
यात्रा में सभी नागरिकों तक बिजली की
पहुंच, शहरीकरण
उद्योजिता विस्तार और जीवन स्तर पर सुधार
के कारण ऊर्जा की आवश्यकता भी तेजी से बढ़
रही है। ऊर्जा की बचत ऊर्जा का सबसे
पर्यावरण अनुरूप और विश्वसनीय स्रोत है।
ऊर्जा संरक्षण केवल एक विकल्प नहीं बल्कि
आज की सबसे महत्वपूर्ण आवश्यकता में से एक
है। ऊर्जा की बचत का अर्थ केवल कम उपयोग
करना नहीं बल्कि समझदारी से जमींदारी से
और दक्षता के साथ ऊर्जा का लाभ उठाना है।
जो हम विद्युत उपकरणों का और आवश्यक उपयोग
नहीं करते हैं। एनर्जी एफिशिएंट उपकरण
अपनाते हैं। घरों और कार्यस्थलों में
नेचुरल लाइट एवं वेंटिलेशन का उपयोग करते
हैं या सोलर एवं रिन्यूएबल एनर्जी को
विकल्प को अपनाते हैं तो हम ना केवल ऊर्जा
बचाते हैं बल्कि कार्बन एमिशंस को भी कम
करते हैं।
स्वच्छ वायु और सुरक्षित जल स्रोतों को
बनाए रखने तथा बालास्ट इको सिस्टम के लिए
भी ऊर्जा की बचत महत्वपूर्ण है। ऊर्जा की
हर यूनिट जो हम बचाएंगे वो प्रकृति के
प्रति हमारी जिम्मेदारी और आने वाली
पीढ़ियों के प्रति हमारी संवेदनशीलता
प्रतीत होता है।
देवियों और सज्जनों, भारत सरकार ने ऊर्जा
संरक्षण और क्लीन एनर्जी ट्रांजिशन के
क्षेत्र में अनेक महत्वपूर्ण कदम उठाए
हैं। भारत ने क्लीन एनर्जी की
प्रतिबद्धताएं समय सीमा से पहले ही पूरी
कर ली है।
यह हमारी ऊर्जा दक्षता और डीकार्बनाइजेशन
की दिशा में बड़ी उपलब्धि है।
राष्ट्रीय स्तर पर प्रधानमंत्री सूर्यघर
मुफत बिजली योजना शुरू की गई है। जिसके
तहत घरों में रूफटॉप सोलर सिस्टम्स लगाए
जा रहे हैं।
इसमें उन घरों को मुफ्त बिजली मिलेगी और
फसिल फ्यूल पर निर्भरता कम होगी। इसके
अलावा रिन्यूएबल कंजमशन ऑब्लिगेशन और
प्रोडक्शन लिंक इंसेंटिव योजनाओं के
माध्यम से रिन्यूएबल एनर्जी अप्शन और
एनर्जी एफिशिएंसी को बढ़ावा दिया जा रहा
है।
इस वर्ष अक्टूबर में मैंने इंटरनेशनल सोलर
अलायंस असेंबली को संबोधित किया था। उस
महत्वपूर्ण मंच पर मैंने रेखांकित किया था
कि सस्ती और स्वच्छ ऊर्जा तक पहुंच
समुदायों को सशक्त बनाती है। इससे स्थानीय
अर्थव्यवस्थाओं को गति मिलती है और आगे
बढ़ने के लिए नए अवसर भी उत्पन्न होती है।
मैंने ये भी कहा था और आज से उसको मैं
दोहराना चाहती हूं कि ग्रीन एनर्जी केवल
विद्युत उत्पादन तक सीमित नहीं है। बल्कि
ये सशक्तिकरण और समावेशी विकास का प्रभावी
माध्यम भी है। देवियों और सज्जनों भारत
ग्रीन हाइड्रोजन टेक्नोलॉजी को क्लीन
एनर्जी ट्रांजिशन का महत्व
हिस्सा बनाते हैं। नेशनल ग्रीन हाइड्रोजन
मिशन के माध्यम से इस क्षेत्र को बढ़ावा
दिया जा रहा है। इस मिशन के अंतर्गत
रिन्यूएबल एनर्जी से ग्रीन हाइड्रोजन
उत्पादन की क्षमता बढ़ाया जा रही है तथा
देश को ग्लोबल हब बनाने और फसिल फल पर
निर्भरता कम करने पर जोर दिया जा रहा है।
अंतरराष्ट्रीय स्तर पर भारत ने अपने
नेशनली डिटरमाइंड कंट्रीबशंस को अपलोड
किया है। जिसे हमारा योगदान ग्लोबल
क्लाइमेट एक्शन में मजबूत हुआ है और विश्व
में सस्टेनेबल डेवलपमेंट और नेट जीरो
गोल्स की दिशा में भारत की प्रभुत्व
भूमिका स्पष्ट हुई है।
मुझे बताया गया है कि वर्ष 2023-24 में
भारत के एनर्जी एफिशिएंसी दिशा में किए गए
प्रयासों से 53.60
मिलियन टन्स ऑफ ऑयल इक्विवेलेंट ऊर्जा की
बचत हुई है।
इन प्रयासों से प्रतिवर्ष आर्थिक बचत हो
रही है और कार्बन डाइऑक्साइड एमिशन में भी
बहुत कमी आई है। मैं इस उपलब्धि के लिए
ऊर्जा मंत्री श्री मनोहर लाल जी और उनकी
पूरी टीम को बहुत-बहुत बधाई देती हूं।
[प्रशंसा]
भारत सरकार ने क्लीनर फ्यूल के लिए एथोनल
ब्लेंडिंग बढ़ाने पर भी जोर दिया है। भारत
ग्लोबल बायोफ्यूल्स अलायंस जैसे
अंतरराष्ट्रीय सहयोग भी कर रहा है ताकि
वेस्ट को वैल्यू में बदला जा सके और भारत
के अनुरूप दुनिया के साथ साझा किया जा
सके।
भारत एक सुव्यवस्थित कार्बन क्रेडिट
ट्रेडिंग स्कीम को भी बढ़ावा दे रहे हैं।
जिसके द्वारा सरकारी और निजी संस्थानों को
अर्थव्यवस्था के डीकार्बनाइजेशन को तेज
करने और एमिशंस कम करने के लिए उत्कृष्ट
प्रयास करने हेतु प्रोत्साहित किया जा रहा
है। मुझे विश्वास है कि यह सभी कदम ऊर्जा
और पर्यावरण के संरक्षण के लिए प्रभावी
सिद्ध होंगे। देवियों और सज्जनों भारत के
एनर्जी ट्रांजिशन की सफलता के लिए
प्रत्येक क्षेत्र और नागरिक की भागीदारी
आवश्यक है। सभी क्षेत्र में ऊर्जा दक्षता
लाने के लिए बिहेवियरल चेंज सबसे
महत्वपूर्ण है।
यह प्रसन्नता की बात है कि सरकार द्वारा
बिहेवियरल चेंज के लिए भी अनेक कार्य
चलाया जा रहा है। प्रकृति के साथ संतुलित
जीवन शैली अपनाने की चेतना भारत की
सांस्कृतिक परंपरा का मूल है।
यह भाव विश्व को दिए गए हमारी संदेश
लाइफस्टाइल फॉर एनवायरनमेंट लाइफ का आधार
है। मैं ऊर्जा संरक्षण के क्षेत्र में
कार्य करने वाले सभी लोगों को तथा विशेष
रूप से बच्चों को बहुत-बहुत बधाई देती
हूं। आपका योगदान आने वाली पीढ़ियों के
लिए एक स्वस्थ और उज्जवल भविष्य सुनिश्चित
करेगा। मुझे पूरा विश्वास है कि सामूहिक
दायित्व साझेदारी और भागीदारी की इस भावना
के साथ भारत ऊर्जा संरक्षण की दिशा में
अग्रणी भूमिका निभाता रहेगा तथा एक हरित
और उज्जवल भविष्य की दिशा में अपने
लक्ष्यों को अवश्य प्राप्त करेगा। आइए
हम संकल्प ले कि ऊर्जा संरक्षण को अपने
जीवन का हिस्सा बनाएं ताकि हमारी धरती
सुरक्षित स्वच्छ और समृद्ध बनी रहे और आने
वाली पीढ़ियां प्रकृति के अनमोल संसाधनों
का आनंद ले सके। धन्यवाद। जय हिंद जय
भारत।